i got a guy whose wife is dming and
hanging out with other dudes
just friends all right let's see what
mike's got where's mike mike mike mike
there's mike
in the house okay so your wife is
yelling and hanging out with him
thanks for bringing me on i appreciate
it i've read your book there um kind of
starting an unplugging process for
myself
um
now
i found out through a friend actually
recommended me uh to you
and your book now my wife i found out
last november-ish that she's been
dm and guys old friends from high school
so a little backstory we've been
together for
13 years now now my question i guess is
you know i've confronted her i've read
the book i'm trying to apply it there's
like a little bit of a ping-pong match
going on in my head with like i respect
her but then on the second second hand
is like well you know how do i unplug i
want your
different view you know it's uh okay so
when you confront her and you say yeah
what are you doing messaging these dudes
like this is uh
number five on my red flag list right
yeah she keeps men from her past around
so she's dming these guys from high
school so what does she say when you
confront her
uh she got defensive at first she's like
well you know what are you doing on my
phone et cetera et cetera so
it's like
yeah she didn't really uh
she didn't really want to like have a
conversation about it it was more like
me having to try and dig it yeah
so is she stay-at-home mom like what
does she do
no we there's not a stay-at-home mom we
don't have kids uh so we've been
together like give you a perspective i'm
32 right now she's 34 um
and then we've been together since i was
19 and she was yeah two years older than
me right so
she works i work um we've been together
since that we've moved around a couple
times so we are in alberta right now in
calgary um kind of give you a little bit
of an idea right
you say here in the private message that
she's hanging out with these other guys
she did right
yeah she at one point there we used to
so we moved around a little bit so i
originally grew up in uh northern part
of alberta and edmonton
uh so she would she while we're together
we she would meet up with them uh
and meet up pal like mike i'm going out
with a friend tomorrow for life yeah
yeah
exactly well you let that happen right i
mean she told you flat out she's going
out with a friend see one of the things
that guys need to understand is when a
woman when women talk about going out
with somebody if it's a chick she's
gonna say i'm gonna go out with my
girlfriend
right if it's a guy what she'll say is
i'm going out with a friend
yeah okay so she told you flat out she
was going with a guy and you let it
happen and that was your first mistake
so what you should have been doing is
like well hold on a second what are you
doing you know hanging out with guys
oh well you're just jealous mike like
you know why are you trying to control
i'm not trying to control you you're my
wife
and yeah i don't deal with women that
hang out with guys from their past
yeah right so you put your foot down and
you're going to get out of life what you
tolerate so this has gone on now for how
long
so that was
like 10 years ago and then 10 years ago
she's been doing this [ __ ] no she did
that 10 years ago prior and the reason
like i'm asking now is because the same
guy that she hung out with
dms her and they were kind of like you
know exchanging you know
you know like inappropriate messages i'd
say like you know hey we had a good time
he has sent her pictures of like them
hanging out like selfies and whatnot so
it's like
i thought it was over the hump like it
was happened like a decade ago right so
we've been together it's been like the
last few years have been great
but then
yeah i found out like last last fall
there it was like oh
yeah you're still talking to them and
that are these people and it's like i
thought our relationship is good but why
are you dming these people right so um
well it's not people it's men like let's
let's be clear right the man yeah we're
just talking to dudes and the only
reason why dudes are talking is because
they want to bang her
right yeah men and women don't have a
lot in common
we just don't right like
men have totally different interests
from most women that's
just the way that it is so saying that
you know oh he's just friends like
nobody [ __ ] more wives than girlfriends
then he's just a friend
guys in the comments you know you tell
me if i'm wrong but you know just chime
in there live so
the thing that you got to do mike is you
got to put your foot down and set some
boundaries around this it's like look if
we're going to be married and you're
going to be my wife you don't talk to
other guys you don't go out with other
guys that's the reality of this
relationship and if you can't do that
you can get [ __ ] and get out right
tell her the door is always open steph
said this to me the other day i was
driving home from one of our meetups the
door is always open on the way out but
it's going to be locked if you try to
come back in
yep absolutely
right but are you gonna do it though now
right like you have the balls to make
sure you put your foot down you you know
set that boundary because if you don't
she's gonna keep walking all over you
yeah i have i have set that boundary and
i basically you know told her like this
is unacceptable behavior so she kind of
got back in my frame as far as i
understand it like i'm new to this whole
red phil thing so um
as far as i see it she's in my frame
she's like oh you know but like i'm kind
of detached too so i'm like
do i want like it's like a back and
forth like you know is this like
the betrayal like i should just go my
separate ways or should i carry on and
try to figure it out right like it's
like uh
i wanted you know well your advice your
private message says found out my wife
is dming and hanging out with other guys
so she's still doing it that hasn't
stopped
yeah not not that i'm aware of yeah so
yeah so it it either stops or she gets
[ __ ] it's as simple as that there's no
in between there's no you know like i'm
not gonna have other guys trying to pork
my wife
yeah
right okay unless you're a cuck i mean
some guys are into that stuff i'm
assuming you're not which is why you're
here right now no i'm not no i just i
wanted uh just some advice right so yeah
dude it's like look it's hard because
you know you've been conditioned all
your life to be a nice guy and just be
less so she can become more and all that
kind of [ __ ] but it's like this is where
guys get to when they let women walk all
over them
and you know then you're in a position
like well this doesn't feel comfortable
because i know she's talking other guys
and hanging out with other guys and
she's telling me they're just friends
like i said earlier nobody [ __ ] more
wives and girlfriends than he's just a
friend
yeah right so it's on you to stop that
and if and if she doesn't stop it and it
keeps going in a direction you don't
like walk you don't have kids who cares
right put the matrimonial assets in a
pile and just get rid of her
right or do you have a scarcity mindset
and you don't think that you can replace
her
no i don't think it's that i think it's
just like i respect her
right because we've been yeah but she
doesn't respect you dude because you set
that boundary and she keeps going over
it
yeah so
you can't like okay look you can stay in
a relationship with a chick that doesn't
respect you millions of guys do it every
day but they're [ __ ] miserable
yeah right there's something dead inside
them and if you want to live that way
that's cool but if you don't then it's
incumbent on you to stand up straight
and say no i'm not having it you're
going to stop it and if you don't we're
done here
right i will replace you
yeah
i think i'm starting to feel that like
the
dead portion there right because it's
like you know it's like it's like a
hollowness almost right but i appreciate
that yeah yeah definitely uh yeah all
right man thanks man hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you